[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the monkeys have revolted
and not just with brute strength or
violence
primates have finally outsmarted
humankind once and for all
[Music]
it's their planet now
how intelligent would monkeys need to be
to take over
what daily threats would exist for a
human like you
and would a monkey planet be more
peaceful than our own
this is what if and here's what would
happen if monkeys took over the world
millions of years ago primates evolved
into different species
there are pro-simians like lemurs and
tarsiers
monkeys like capuchins and cats
and apes like gorillas and chimpanzees
you are also part of this primate order
humans share a common ancestor and 98.6
of our dna with chimpanzees
you may be the most intelligent monkey
but other primates are clever too
they can communicate recognize family
and use tools
what if tomorrow instead of running
experiments on monkeys
they started running experiments on you
if monkeys took over the planet it would
certainly be a revolution led by highly
intelligent primates
these would be either transgenic monkeys
or ones enhanced with brain implants
if you're wondering what on earth
transgenic monkeys are
those are artificially created monkeys
that carry a human gene
if these smartypants escaped research
facilities into areas with high
populations of non-modified monkeys it
could spell trouble for us
one hot spot would be lopbury thailand
here thousands of monkeys live on city
streets
there are even several no-go zones that
have been taken over by rival monkey
gangs
another would be florida's silver spring
state park
there's a thriving population of
macaques there likely descendants of
theme park escapees
hyper-intelligent monkeys could train
these populations in the best ways to
wage war on humans
if you live in brazil madagascar
indonesia or the democratic republic of
congo
your country might be one of the first
to fall
that's because 65
of all primate species live in these
places
if you are in europe you would be safe
because there are no wild native
primates
but humans fleeing armies of monkeys to
a safe zone would create a devastating
refugee crisis
but how exactly would monkeys be able to
pull off a revolution against humans
communication would be a key part of
their strategy
societal roles would have to be
delegated based on the different levels
of intelligence
apes like chimpanzees gorillas and
bonobos are among the smartest so they
would play prominent roles in the
uprising
orangutans are also highly intelligent
and could manufacture weapons
they are known to be more capable than
children of making tools
for example a fishing hook
if they learned how to make spears
they could attack us from the ground and
above
you would have a real fight on your
hands
orangutans have another remarkable
ability
they are the only known non-human
primates that can communicate about the
past
they would use this intellectual skill
to observe us and then signal our
movements to other monkeys once we were
gone
monkeys would communicate with visual
clues auditory calls and olfactory
signals
it would be hard for us to keep up and
would take time to learn their ways
unfortunately monkey society would
likely be as dangerous as our own
perhaps maybe even more so he will see
we are not savages chimpanzees have been
observed to invade the territories of
other chimpanzee groups systematically
so they would kill other primates for
food
in
1974 scientist dr jane goodall witnessed
intergroup violence that she described
as a war that annihilated an entire
community
but the numbers
would be in your favor
with around 60 percent of earth's
primate species currently threatened
with extinction
they wouldn't stand much of a chance
against 7.8 billion humans
still considering the devastating
effects of deforestation and years of
extremely invasive experiments on
monkeys
humans have a lot of wrongs to repent
for
let's hope the intelligent monkeys come
to us in peace
which means we'll only have to worry
about machines taking over the planet
but that's a story
for another
what if
you